a computer managed to beat the world
champion of strategy board game go and
this robot dog could end up replacing
our pets these are the latest
achievements in artificial intelligence
the algorithms behind these IT programs
are everywhere including in the media
and they can be used to spread fake news
but they could also be part of the
solution
this was the focus of the Parliament's
annual science lecture it's more
important to make sure that we have
algorithms that give us more options
they give us all the titles around the
issue and then we decide what we want to
believe with sometimes an opinion or a
speculation is something that you cannot
identify as faked using algorithms
websites can create a video based on an
article without any human help but
because the algorithms themselves are
designed by humans they can help spread
misinformation and discriminatory
content more and more sites are
developing ways of controlling what
information is put on the Internet we
developed a product truly media that
does exactly that it gives the
journalist in a newsroom immediate
results from artificial intelligent
tools that will check the source that
will check the photo if there's if it's
manipulated the real challenge behind
this is how to help readers identify
credible content online and access
better quality journalism